j'adore votre nouvelle coloration ce que
vous pouvez me dire ma déclaration il
sait quoi elle va là bas c'était pour
infirmer ce qui ne leur est plus
acheminé donc j'en ai fait une moi même
ma maison je le déconseille à tout le
monde d'accord vous n'êtes pas content
d'évoluer professionnellement personnes
non et bien imaginez la tête deux hommes
pointent bull hockey pond a ok
aussi ouais bah
ma pire et des tatouages je n'ai pas
encore fait et je vais la faire et j'ai
hâte que vous la voyez mais c'est
vraiment très très moche c'est avec une
botte à moi on devait statuer ensemble
elle a rêvé que je dessinais un dessin
d'enfant clairement un château avec son
cheval de vent ils vont se faisant
tatouer ça du coup pour déconner j'ai
fait le dessin c'est immonde c'est
vraiment immonde donc je vais avoir un
cheval dégueulasse tatouage sur le bras
j'ai hâte de vous montrer vous voulez
voir le cheval en question je vais me
faire tatouer donc à la base le dessin
entier c'est ça et j'aime pour sa fille
je vais vraiment faire ça se fait ça
[Musique]
choco
ona américaine instant
non
autonomes